over the past several months parents
have woken up to a problem that has been
going on for a very very long time and
it's been increasing in its severity
namely
teachers
are indoctrinating america's children
in the craziest wokest most destructive
nonsense that one could possibly imagine
the problem seems to be getting worse
and worse every day so we are going to
go over the uh four wokest teachers that
i have come across on tiktok because
it's not just enough that the teachers
are spatting off this nonsense in the
classroom they're also broadcasting it
on tiktok so we're going to look through
the four locus teachers i've seen on
tiktok and we are going to decide which
one of these teachers should be fired
before we begin this video is sponsored
by ring no matter your home ring has
everything you need to protect it more
from them in a minute without further
ado let's get started
so i just
came out to my students
i've been wanting to do this for the
past two years
what's she doing i'm like so emotional
um and i just haven't had the courage to
do it came out out of fear of just
judgment mostly from their parents
but
i had these kids in fourth grade and
now i have them in six and i'm sending
them to middle school and i love these
kids so much and i trust them and they
make me feel safe and
i know they love me and
just felt right and i i did it and
it was so beautiful
[Music]
they had so many questions which
i loved they wanted to learn and they
wanted to learn about me and
they were so eager and
a few of them clapped which was
so precious
okay so the problem here is not even
that this woman is a lesbian i assume
she's a lesbian i guess these days you
can come out as like a man or as your
sexual desire or as an animal or so you
can come out as a lot of things but i'm
assuming that she's using this in the
normal way that people use this term and
that she's a lesbian the issue is not so
much that she likes chickies as that she
is
one
discussing her sex life at all with her
students and and even beyond the sex
stuff that she's making the lesson all
about her that's really bad
i had a number of gay teachers as a
student i suspect everybody did some of
my favorite teachers were gay as a
matter of fact they didn't make being
gay a major aspect of their identity in
fact most of the i think i don't know
that any of them actually broadcast that
fact at all i don't they just didn't
they just didn't talk about their sex
lives with their students because they
were normal people okay they were normal
responsible people who made the lesson
about the subject that they were
teaching and put the focus on the
students and their education not on
their own sexual desires and lusts and
preferences so that's that's a big
problem and also then it leads into this
problem of
she is not only ex revealing some aspect
of her sexual desire to her students but
she is indoctrinating them into a
certain
sexual morality regardless of what that
sexual morality is is that the role of a
teacher or is that the role of
parents within their own
religious philosophical ethical
frameworks you're not my dad that's
pretty bad stuff
she if she should be fired it does not
just because she's a lesbian or whatever
you know she would make it out about her
identity but it's about what she
believes her role is in her students
lives and i think she's really
overstepping you're fired all right next
one i love my new school my hair hasn't
been a problem and i taught a lesson
last week where we read the first letter
from the book dear martin you know the
one where he realizes that he was
arrested for no reason because he was
black even though he thought he was
exempt because he wasn't one of those
kinds of people who that happens to but
it turns out that doesn't matter because
of the prejudice in the criminal justice
system and we discussed that this lesson
was developed by the english department
and approved by the overseer of the
english department
imagine that getting to talk about and
discuss things relative to the students
lives regardless of how some people
might feel about it because the people
who would be offended
are the bad guys it's just so refreshing
for there to be some open-mindedness to
be able to teach something meaningful
again open-minded doesn't she seem so
open-minded
they're the anyone who disagrees with my
completely fictional narrative about
justice in america
is a bad guy they're bad if they're
conservative students or their parents
are bad or their
society is bad or all of all of the
above
i had not heard of this book the premise
of this book is is fictional that uh you
know black people are accosted and
persecuted by the police on the basis of
their race it just isn't true it just
doesn't happen it's fiction if anything
actually the the systemic racism that
exists in our system only cuts in one
way the only
legal systemic racism in our system is
to disadvantage white and asian people
specifically students specifically with
regard to
college and school applications to
affirmative action and to give advantage
on the basis of race to black and
hispanic students so uh what she's
teaching is wrong so i guess she could
be fired for that reason if i the reason
that i have a little bit of sympathy for
this woman is that she had the lesson
plan approved by the administrators so
really it doesn't seem fair that she
gets fired but the administrators don't
get fired i don't think that's an
argument for not firing her i think
that's an argument for firing the head
of the english department and the
administrators yes
you know when you want to keep yourself
safe not just in school not just from
crazy stupid harmful destructive ideas
but from bad guys from delivery people
from your in-laws i would strongly
recommend you check out
ring go check out the ring alarm
security system i really love it it just
gives me peace of mind okay i love that
when i am either in my home actually or
at the office or on the road or on a
beach on the other side of the world i
can be safe that my wife and my child
will know who is outside the door before
they open up that door you all know that
ring's doorbell where you can see and
speak to whoever's at the door well the
ring alarm system allows you to see
every inch of your house okay wherever
you are all from that simple app protect
your home anytime from anywhere with
ring alarm go to ring.com knowles for a
special offer on the ring alarm security
kit today you can build a system that is
right for your home and have it up and
running in minutes that's
ring.comring.com
k-w-l-e-s
all right let's see which teacher is
next up to be fired you want to know why
i want to know why he brought the trump
flag
what
so i'm going to say it's politically
correct
to make a lot of the african-american
kids mad so that was his motive do you
support him now
so he's racing
yes
i mean everyone here supporting him free
colton
his best friend is what fake news
okay so
this teacher here is saying that if you
support the duly elected president of
the united states that you're a trash
person and you're racist and you're
terrible and you're going to be punished
that is worse than the the other things
we've seen are pretty bad that
that is worse that is actually more
radical than you know spouting off about
your sexual desires in class or
spreading a bunch of lies about the
criminal justice system
and calling conservatives the bad guys
this is this is actually even more
extreme than that right now i think this
this lady is the front runner you also
are fired my classroom is one of the
gayest places probably on the planet
everything is completely covered in
rainbows i've got flags everywhere i've
got queer literature because i want
every student that i have to know that
being queer is something that i am proud
of something that is not um a secret in
my life it's something that i care about
and something that connects me to other
people i'll end by saying that for me
being visibly queer is a non-negotiable
i introduced myself this year with my
pronouns immediately it was the one of
the first things that students learned
about me and i'm going to continue to
gently correct 250 people every single
day because my identity is a critical
part of who i am so if education is
something that you want to pursue um i
recommend being steadfast and being
committed to being out as an educator if
it's something that you feel safe doing
um it has a huge impact for students and
it's something that i've never regretted
okay so this woman is obviously very
confused i assume woman i don't know she
says that she is non-binary which is not
a thing it's not real it's a total
fabrication it's imaginary it is a
delusion and someone who is that deluded
about
nature and about the human person
obviously should not be in a position to
teach people things because as this
teacher says she will correct
those ignorant
students who believe that there are men
and there are women that they're
different and that there are not other
sexes i do think these people come by
them honestly either they've got some
problems where they just can't they are
not aware of their true sex or they have
been just deluded by lots and lots of
ideology to not even be able to
understand the difference between a man
and a woman now
but i do think they come by that
honestly
and so obviously they should not be in
the classroom but i still don't think
that's quite as egregious a
transgression as screaming at a student
and saying that if you support the
president you're a trash person and you
ought to be punished i mean that i think
the number one teacher who ought to be
fired and really sort of punished for
what she's doing should be that that
teacher in the third video the one who
is yelling at this calling students
racist and trash for supporting trump
[Applause]
but certainly this this non-binary
lady should should not be teaching
students she's
not because she's some evil person or
something just because she doesn't
understand very basic facts about the
world and so she shouldn't be educating
people you're fired she should become
educated herself and
i i don't even mean that to insult her
but if you want to get along in the
world you need to understand
reality and if you want to flourish it
helps to exercise your faculties of
reason and and bring your your delusions
into accord with with reality and uh so
i i would probably fire multiple
teachers here but but certainly number
one would be would be that lady and i by
the way we should point out here when i
say we should fire the teachers i'm not
saying we should just you know sort of
reprimand them or put a slap on the
wrist or you know we should have a free
marketplace of ideas where we don't
cancel anybody because we don't want to
have cancer culture i'm not saying that
that is some squish libertarian nonsense
a fifth grade classroom is not a free
marketplace of ideas academic freedom is
a hoax that is how william f buckley jr
described it when he launched the
conservative movement with a book called
god and man at yale subtitled the
superstitions of academic freedom it's
just a an instrument it's a tool that
the left uses to try to up end
traditional standards this is the thesis
of my book speechless controlling words
controlling minds which i'm pleased to
say is number one national bestseller
even though it's been suppressed by a
lot of left-wing outlets so don't buy
into that crap this idea that these
lunatics have the right to destroy your
children's education they don't you have
the right to take back your children's
education you have the right to raise
your children and not let them be raised
by these very confused often radical and
uh in some cases extremely vindictive
people fire the bad teachers get fired
cancel them it is all societies all
cultures cancel okay the question is
what do we cancel do we cancel people
who are saying good and true things or
do we cancel people who are saying false
and kooky and destructive things i think
it ought to be the latter
cancel the bad teachers we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]